what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to
low loaded featuring hot boy hard times
this was one of the songs that was sent
to me on my instagram
so if you guys want to submit any music
or other videos that you want me to
react to
send it to me on my instagram before i
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel as you guys know i'm trying to
hit 20 000 subscribers and each and
every one of you
helps me get to that goal while you're
at it hit that notification bell to be
notified when i post my daily
videos okay
this is
then it ain't filmed right i hope this
doesn't
wait film the night before loda turned
himself into custom
custody on the outstanding murder
warrant oh god
wait we done had hard times gotta know
they ain't forever
[Music]
okay
[Music]
just so you guys know i don't know any
of the backstory so
the murder warrant or whatever
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i really like this song so far i think
that's a really good message
that um you know that even when stuff is
tough
that in the future it's going to get
better and you have more of like life to
look forward to because i can imagine
if you're born into like not that great
of a situation it might seem like that's
going
to be forever when you really have your
whole life ahead of you everything's
shining
in my city i won't let them take me out
real killer really got some paper now i
hear triple d [ __ ] rocking with them
haitians now
team full of killers like we on the
lakers now feel the time to talk they
know imma make it now i'm feeling tight
to trust they know i'ma make it out
rock out rock out i'm a rockstar
[Music]
okay i don't i don't know if the epitome
of good
times should be a a strip club
but i actually am really enjoying this
song so i'm not going to say too much
about that
um i'm confused where the murder warrant
like comes in
because in the beginning of the song
they talked about like a murder warrant
so i was expecting this song to be like
very different vibes but now he's like
it's like kind of an inspiring
song with a i really like the beat like
i really
enjoy this solid [ __ ] you gotta know
that she get better with the hell
out of time gotta know they ain't
forever stay solid [ __ ] you gotta know
this [ __ ] get better we don't have
our time gotta know they ain't forever
stay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
get better
[Music]
[Music] [Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so he's saying even though he's a
big
star and he's like doing well that to
the opposition
and to the cops he's a target so
um i've heard this a lot and just like
some of the rapper like
beef um stuff that i've like listened to
that the like bigger a rapper gets the
bigger like
target he has on his back allegedly
you gotta know that they get better
gotta know they ain't forever
stay solid
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay this is crazy this is
probably my favorite song
maybe not number one but i would say top
five favorite songs i've listened to on
this channel i'm gonna give this one a
five out of five
um i thought it was really catchy i
thought it had like a good message
overall um i'm not sure where the murder
charge came in so maybe like
yeah i'm gonna just ignore the beginning
but let me know in the comments if you
guys
agree with the analysis or you disagree
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel
and bring the notification
bell